Hunter Biden's corrupt House of Cards
could soon be crumbling down the first
Sun appearing in court today in Arkansas
and facing off against the mother of his
four-year-old love child a little girl
that Hunter hasn't even met and that
President Biden refuses to even
acknowledge Hunter wants to lower his
child support payments
the mother is accusing Hunter of lying
about his income and wants the judge to
throw him in jail until he comes clean
about how much he makes
so this isn't just your ordinary child
support fight the case could blow the
lid off where the Biden family gets all
the cash from and whether the big guy is
getting his cut the judge just ordered
Hunter to answer additional written
questions about his Investments his art
sales and other Financial transactions
James Comer says those developments
could be keyed as investigation
we want to know how much money he's made
from the artwork and who the buyers are
that's the most important part who the
buyers of this artwork are we want to
know if Hunter Biden has any offshore
accounts because we're learning more
every day about the the complex scheme
that the Biden family had to try to
disguise the source of the revenue so I
think this court case has a lot of
potential to help assist us in our
investigation such as what kind of
things would Hunter answer to these
written questions that could help James
Comer's investigation
the amazing part of this is you've got
the Department of Justice the FBI the
IRS Congressional oversight and they
will not be able to get anywhere near
what a family court judge in Arkansas
will get in this case this family court
judge is a straight shooter based upon
everything that I've been reading about
her she's requiring that that he
answered additional questionnaires and
she is criticizing his lawyers for
overly redacting disclosures and
finances she has ordered that Hunter
testify in June in a deposition and that
they go to trial in July now what this
does is it blows the whole thing open
because Hunter and by the way let me you
know who started this Hunter because
it's such a cheapskate he went in for a
reduction of Child Support himself so
the London the mother says you know my
little girl Navy has never even seen her
father she's not acknowledged by her
grandfather who's the president of the
United States the they put stockings on
the on the uh uh for Christmas up for
the dog and every other grandchild but
not for his his grandchild here and I
want I want my daughter to use the Biden
name and he outrageously says oh it's a
terrible thing it will it will destroy
her if she uses my name the truth is
he's sold and made fortunes on his name
and he wants to deny his daughter a vet
but what we're seeing here is an
original settlement of two and a half
million dollars so he's paid 750
allegedly that's according to the
lawyers so everybody take him with a
grain of salt this judge is going to
force him to follow through on that
Financial settlement and if he shows
that he doesn't have the money she's
going to keep digging this is a judge
who's going to go in for with a forensic
accountant and make sure that the hunter
Biden and his family as a result of the
connections cannot hide the money that
this baby is entitled to and think about
the psychological the emotional damage
that this child will go through when she
realizes how embarrassed they were how
they tried to hide a little girl shame
on that are Democrats Jessica
embarrassed
writ large no are you a little
I'm embarrassed that anyone would deny a
child like this whoever they are I think
it's an awful story and the fact that
it's now playing out all over our TV
screens and in our papers makes it even
worse things like this go on every day
and the judge was saying that she sat as
a family court judge for a little while
and has seen this that this is something
that goes on but obviously this is on
another level because it involves the
president of the United States and it
doesn't seem particularly in line with
the kind of ethos of this family or what
they have projected is the ethos I do
think that if it if the judge's
assessment is right and this family
court judge will blow the lid off the
whole thing that that's going to be good
for all of us to finally know what the
financials are if there's a connection
to the big guy hopefully this girl will
get her two and a half million dollar
settlement in full but most of all I
would like Jim Comer to stop going on TV
and saying got this got this do you
actually and then he goes well if this
and if that just draw the connection
draw the straight line and then we can
all go home well he did draw the
straight line from China to the Biden
family bank account Dana your thoughts
on how this is playing out well I think
the judge's point about Hunter being the
one who started this is a really good
one because a lot of people might say oh
well this woman and she's just money
hungry she's a money grubby no she has a
child that she has to care for who knows
but they probably even have to have
security I would imagine and why but
she's never met her dad she's never met
her grandfather or her grandmother Dr
Jill Biden who the the bidens have said
look we are such a wonderful loving
family and look at look at us we are a
great family and we forgive our son
Hunter for all of his
um transgressions that he had and his
addiction and we're so proud of him
because he overcame his addiction so
aside from the money part of things to
me this is a matter of character for all
of them because at what point doesn't
the president say son just do the right
thing let's do the right thing let's
make sure she has the financial needs
means that she has but I want to know
her I mean let me just back up so when I
was growing up my grandfather on my
dad's side with the Rancher he was such
an important influence in my life and
when I think back to men in my life who
have been the most helpful to me and
shaping me and helping me have
confidence and being able to be who I am
today it was my grandfather that I
looked to that I think about in my
mind's eye and that I remember so fondly
and I think a lot of women feel that way
this girl as the judge said she will
always know that they completely ignored
her and for what for politics
when actually I think the politics for
them would have been so much better if
they had said Hunter just do the right
thing and I want to know her and London
you are welcome here at the what you are
welcome here to our beach house and yes
I know Hunter you have a new wife deal
with it and she's going to get to know
her cousins and she's going to get to
know her stepbrother stepsister and it
it really does break my heart and again
this is not the right wing who has come
up with this story Hunter Biden had the
affair
had the child denied paternity denied
didn't want to pay tried to reduce the
amount he was going to pay has fought it
every step of the way and this judge
isn't out to get the bidens she's out to
help the child and we should all follow
it that way and the president has money
he could loan Hunter some coin to help
this Navy out or maybe start selling his
paintings right and then that could pay
for whatever he owes because he does
paint like a four-year-old it seems only
fitting it is amazing to you the
original uh denial do you know what his
denial was he doesn't remember
if only we could always say that about
everything I don't remember he said he
had so much sex he doesn't remember
still I do think it is a mistake to let
the hunters human failings become the
story because that that could be
separated this you know his human
failings didn't bury the laptop we need
to get to the real story of influence
peddling and on behalf of the big guy
that matters more still you have to
think about this is the granddaughter of
the president of the United States and
he ignores her I mean she earned that
place her mother slept with Hunter Biden
think about that that's like sleeping
with Force square blocks a skid row I
mean that's like that's worse than going
that's worse than going into war there's
a but much much darker scarier risk but
I I know that I bet you old President
Joe is confused by all this because in
the old days they probably handled this
differently you know this this person
went away because how many politicians
back in the old days had illegitimate
kids and they just disappeared and then
you'd hear rumors and what happened to
them or you just paid the woman off
right most of these politicians and he
won't even do that at least I mean Chad
yeah Donald Trump he he slept with the
porn stars but he paid them
can I just mention one other thing that
and look this reporter I'm not this
isn't a knock on the reporter but at the
White House Correspondents Dinner
there's this Washington Post reporter
and he got honored for his job and he
does a good job but what they awarded
him for was about how Joe Biden's
Catholic faith shapes the way he
approaches his job yeah I mean
what what is this because we've brought
this up that nobody wants to talk about
and this is a President Who abort a kid
up to the timetables right you know it's
like and make the taxpayers pay for it
yeah all right coming up Sanctuary City
Democrats are begging for mercy from
Republican Governors sending them more
migrants all right hi everyone I'm Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now